[Applaudissements]
dix mois ouais là qu'il est devenu beau
gosse sur la toya jackson c'est vrai
qu'il vous plaît ça ouais non et me tape
tape tout a volé mes costumes c'est
comme ça que vous voulez je m'habille
john viennent
je voudrais pour vous allez bien non non
c'est je sais pas on m'a dit mais ça je
dis ok écouter sur la barre il est très
cool surtout savez ces modèles seront
traînés sefyu tu connais geneviève pour
ces finales et qu'est ce qu'on a alors
qu'est ce qu'on a on va commencer tout
de suite avec un double zumba de zumba
bas de niveau ligue des champions
j'adore tout d'abord regardez bien votre
tête sous les halles a répondu gauclin
manquant vous demander si vous faire
partir en vacances avec vous ou avec
yann barthès celui avec qui tu voudrais
jamais parti en vacances je pense que
c'est moi et moi je veux partir en
vacances avec ma femme
pourquoi dis ça et la meilleure la tête
de cyril hanouna quand il apprend ce cas
dans sa nourriture préférée
les nuggets et les nuggets croyez que
c'est de la viande peu dingue est
celesio et boyaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rabat
[Applaudissements]
tu manges des nuggets suis aussi jedoch
ouais ouais ils s'aiment old qui gagnera
si moi j'ai plus ciciba non mais tu
cours presque aussi vite que lui la
boîte de 12 volts et franchement usain
bolt sur qui fait 100 km quand toi tu as
fait ton mais non c'est qu'on passe le
test en a déjà couru tuque ont vite elle
voulait pas qu'on fasse un 100 m demain
comment vos 200 m sans rigoler sauf un
saurien 1
enfin 100 m oui tu veux tout mais alors
pas de quoi leur doctorat de 19h à 21h
et les gens qui vous vous rendez vous
qu'au sport il est il est impressionnant
à bilal oui c'est que c'est bon mais
impressionnant dans tout et quand tu
veux faire quelque chose il veut
toujours gagner ces groupes à mon chéri
ouais hein
j'aime ça et vous gagnez comme toi au
tennis à lacets bac bac au tennis à côté
de bretagne historique et sa côte est
n'est ce pas côtés de pierre côté nice
mme m
merci d'être là ouais merci à vous de
m'inviter cinq soirs n'est pas invité si
tu peux être invité ça nous fera vers
des écoles de cyril jeunechamp sur ce
thème bien doc gynéco oui je connais une
de ses chansons
bah ça c'est difficile d'avoir le
docteur non n'ai pas peur mais de moi
danser ce soir
la bohème mais n'a pas bien su encore à
jean ferrat non que la montagne est
belle et chansons c'est quoi que ce soit
des plans dans l'édition
je trouve et attaquer makossa et la
montagne est belle et c'est un homme qui
est devenu en quelques mois le nouveau
chouchou des téléspectateurs de
l'émission c'est dominique oui on a donc
la confirmation que pour être un bon
chroniqueur médias n'y a pas besoin de
faire des études
il suffit de boire des coups et dormir
et c'est le truc c'est le truc qui
marche on a trouvé le gars qui bosse
encore moins que jean michel mr et qui
est devenu aussi indispensable que
valérie benaïm sur ces 8 bruno est
tellement fatigué que je lui remets le
laurier du gars qui ne devrait pas
s'appeler doc gynéco mais d'origine et
chaos
et oui on essaye
les concepts d'émissions de télé doc
gynéco il est connaît tous par coeur
c'est important votre avis sur the voice
j'ai trouvé que jennifer à 100 m quand
elle se retourne c'est que c'est bon bah
c'est le concept de limites bien on va
chez quelqu'un au monde et ne connais
absolument rien de la carrière de
mathieu delormeau yaté qu avant avant de
venir ici c'est quoi sa carrière il
faisait encore émission en revanche
utiliser des pancartes c'est pas du tout
son truc quand la question ces bonnes ou
mauvaises idées voilà ce que répond le
dos je mate et c'est tout le temps comme
ça
kimiko sous steam alliant nakamura doc
gynéco des jeunes écossais le gâter
paiement à l'ouest qu'il est toujours
étonné celui qui niveau parole est
toujours en bas débit
doc gynéco
[Applaudissements]
étonné quand il découvre au bout d'une
heure que matthieu delormeau n'est pas
là vous avez mis combien mais mature et
surtout souvenez-vous que doc gynéco
c'est le seul gars qui dit bonjour alors
que l'émission est presque fini bonsoir
à tous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors cyril hanouna on sait tous que
c'est un génie de la télévision c'est
monsieur le guen qui arrive de faire un
million trois cent mille personnes pour
un prime de deux heures où ils pèsent
des valises
[Rires]
c'est exactement forme c'est une
revanche sur dans 22 pays se trouve la
chaussure en concert vraiment alors on
le sait est aussi un expert pour faire
avouer aux gens des choses qui n'ont pas
du tout envie de vous raconter comme ce
pauvre eric antoine qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il a été contacté par une chaîne
alors vous allez le cuisiner voici un
nouvel épisode de l'inspecteur la bavure
la bavure
[Musique]
comptez ni compo anne vien a touche pas
à mon poste il ne s'attend certainement
pas à subir un terrible interrogatoire
de l'inspecteur la bavure avoue le
toutes les chaînes aussitôt débaucher
situerait sur m6 ça commence comme tous
les suspects ont quelque chose à cacher
eric antoine béguin non non non
n'auraient pas toutes les chaînes non
mais un groupe de chaînes à groupe de
chaînes et regardez là thème de
l'inspecteur la bavure
il jubile du haut de ses deux mètres 0
scène eric antoine tremble c'est alors
que l'inspecteur la bavure en remettent
une couche on est au courant mais qui
nous tue sud je sais c'était plutôt
laissé tous les partis je sais tout tu
fait flipper eric antoine passe donc aux
avoue je sais quoi la télé des contacts
avec france télévisions oui oui voilà
mais avec tout le monde voilà tout le
monde t'aime c'est vrai qu'ils ont eu
raison de penser à toi encore une
enquête rondement menée par l'inspecteur
la bavure
[Musique]
ouais ouais alors alors mais c'est vrai
et je vous le dis france télévisions
voulait absolument eric antoine
voilà ils ont raison voilà mais sachez
que france télévisions j'aurai des
grosses infos sur eux il prépare je vous
le dis dès prime très très fort à la
rentrée de septembre
non seulement il ya le truc a écrit
teddy riner carrick qui va être un
énorme carton joly le concept est fou à
et derrière été dit c'est mon vrai
cousin de sang s'était dit bert ou teddy
riner teddy riner
pourquoi c'est votre cousin était vénéré
ouais c'est fou quoi mais à l'école
devrait dire le judo avec mon ami et moi
c'est vrai que teddy riner ouais ouais
judokas ouais ouais vous avez fait des
sports de combat vous moi je n'ont quà
g8 ni regard de quoi tu sais tu non non
quoi il prend les 26 bat contre des mecs
de de l'est où ça ils les jettent comme
des feuilles en papier sont méfiés way
s'est amassée principe de teddy riner
on le voit d'ailleurs teddy est il donc
t'es dit que j'aime ça il viendra nous
voir et je peux vous dire on est en
train de préparer des très gros show
avec france télévisions autour de cette
émission pour la rentrée et c'est vrai
qu'on s'entend très bien avec la
direction de france télévisions voilà je
vous le dit et il prépare des choses
énormes en prime time
notamment pour le samedi soir ils vont
faire une très très grosse année je vous
dis papa m'avait milieu d'une mer de
noir donnant mon numéro de téléphone
enfin que du coup tous les directeurs
des programmes ont l'ancien la fin de
saison excuse parce prépare sur france
télévisions et tout ça alors il pense à
bout du quai de télévision et je sais et
du coup je vais
ils sont à la recherche de bouc pour
motus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour finir hier soir dans l'émission
nous recevions denitsa ikonomova et
maxime des rennaises et danseur vedette
de danse avec les stars
ouais et cyril vous avez une fois hyper
gentil bah oui je t'aime l'hérault
gentil vous a notamment sorti une phrase
magnifique sur danse avec les stars
phrase qui me force à nouveau avant m le
laurier de pippo man mais je vous le dis
ils veulent se faire danser les stars
donc là où il faut y aller l'année mais
qu'il faut que la jouer du gros casting
a malheureusement raté pmp avec nous
donc on est fan a toujours été avec vous
le dis mais c'est vrai c'est que vous
avez toujours soutenu danse avec les
stars
la preuve je peux pas ses missions il a
toujours été avec vous le dis je déteste
cette émission mais vous aimez la danse
je vous dis on a toujours été avec pas
le redire sans foi peut avoir n'importe
quoi en phase on regarderait n'importe
quoi jeanne a toujours été avec vous le
dire mais c'est l'émission de tri car je
peux passer son placement jeunes a
toujours été avec vous le dis oui
[Musique]
est-ce que j'ai pas toujours fait la
promotion danse avec les stars
il est la vérité après avori chaude
comprend avant et c'était avant je ne
comprenais rien la danse pina voilà puis
j'ai changé mais c'est vrai que je suis
pas commun voilà je te défend la vision
c'est un beau show mais bon je ne
regarde jamais dans sec les stars non je
la monnaie mais c'est un beau show très
bien qu'à mais j'aime bien et est très
fort merci beaucoup je sais reconnaître
par cédric ciza fait du bon boulot
merci à l'anti fait sa dernière
chronique assez père décédé trois fois
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]